hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to dream daddy now this game
is sorry I just caught up in the music
there for a second this is the first
time I loaded it up so I haven't heard
that music yet uh the dad tips on it's
so good do what you love and the money
will come oh that's such a good tip when
changing a tire make sure to tighten the
bolts in a starfish pattern okay so
before I get started I wanted to say
that this game is made by Vernon Shawn
Leighton gray now Vernon and I we go way
back to the first time we filmed hot
pepper gaming together but also this
game is produced by the game grumps and
there's tons of other people that also
had a hand in it anyway I just wanted to
give a shout out to the people that made
this game because it's one of the first
games that came out to her from the
let's play world in a way yes made by
the game grumps produced by the game
grumps so anyway oh hi daddy's the one
video this is the one series where it's
acceptable for me to say the word Daddy
now that doesn't give you the right to I
can't stop you if you do but just if
we're gonna get through this we need
some base rules here I'm gonna be called
a lot of people daddy I'm gonna probably
fall in love with a lot of guys here
beautiful it's something so beautiful Oh
Z Z Z Z Z Z table dad dad wake up let's
pretend to be dead yeah I do that oops I
let my tongue roll out of my mouth and
stop breathing Amanda shakes me come on
dad this hasn't worked on me since I was
six I'm sorry Amanda this is the end for
me dad I swear to god Amanda I bequeath
to you all of my earthly possessions
spread my ashes over my recliner okay
well your course better get into the
moving van because it's leaving soon I
finally opened my eyes and sit up I'm
lying in the middle of the living room
spooning a moving
looks a yawn and stretch morning man to
Panda
yikes dad breath go brush your teeth
okay all right
try not to make assumptions about people
great dad - OH
Krillin is that you brilliant Oh got a
pit pick my dad bod fine let's see all
right oh good dad bod Oh
nice bear bod I don't know how many
people know this but I'm not a very
hairy man so oh sure I was born oh it's
a difference between a crop top not crop
top okay well I gotta go with the not
crop in the no hair where's the longest
head in this game how do you get the
most square head these aren't these
aren't nearly big enough oh so cool
maybe this get a real daddy going on it
well I think I gotta go is side part
because it's kind of what it is for me
if I was to and let me flip the other
way here let's see just spread it it's
like spread into two sections of
yourself and wait all right is that
pretty close I'm pretty close I'll go
with that one oh don't stare at me like
that all right we got sweet brown eyes
like a [ __ ] shade of brown piercing eyes
that's gotta close Oh dots Charlie Brown
s see if you either between this one
oh man those are seductive I'd like to
think I have seductive eyes that's
pretty good she knows big big nose give
me the biggest you got big big big nose
big German Fishbach goes in here
uh yeah wide nose that's probably it oh
yeah oh my god go with that yeah I was
looking less like me by the second oh
hell yeah I think we found a winner
[Laughter]
which one of these where's the
sleeveless ones all these have sleeves
on well I guess I'm wearing white today
so I would be fitting Oh Burgie Oh Danny
Oh Mabel BAE Oh egg nips
god I love egg nips mmm oh that's a good
one oh these are all good man I need to
buy new clothes these all look so good
oh [ __ ] dude I'm gonna go with this one
this daddy is looking good oh my god
this daddy is looking fine Oh Oh looking
good daddy
looking good Oh mark
Mark II Pierre ah yes
if you guys ever seen a more handsome
daddy in your life don't answer that
hang on daddy whoa daddy hey B that I am
that dad hell yeah oh you always have
time for a beer with your buds what I
can't drink I can't do it did you fall
asleep packing I got most of it done I
think searching around the room it looks
like I did a pretty good job every box
is sealed except for one weight
straggler what's in it looking into the
box I see a bunch of old photos and
little photo albums whoa I haven't seen
these in years I pull out one of the
dusty albums on top of the pile and
we've been looking through it oh oh so
cute that's the coolest baby I ever seen
let's see the only way your father and I
the only way your mother and I I guess
it's a daddy game so I'm gonna go with
father and I
I mean if I'm gonna be dating daddies
that's probably I was gonna be going
yeah the only way your father and I
could get you to stop crying was to put
the sunglasses on Yin but whenever we
tried to take them off you'd start
crying again you little baby you spent
the first two years of your life with
sunglasses on nice Halloween when you
were maybe four oh my god that dragon
costume you couldn't decide between
being a princess or a dragon so you went
with bolt princess dragon why do I
remember crying in that dragon costume
you saw yourself in the mirror and
realize you were afraid of dragons
seeing yourself inside the dragon's
mouth was a realization your greatest
fear I think right yep definitely
repress that memory and this was you in
your horse face I believe you named that
plush horse sir horsing tyndall brave
Amanda lunges for the photo but I
quickly snatched it away and hold it
above her head with my superior dad arms
arms nice try but this is important
blackmail for later down the road go
ahead and try me I've seen pictures of
you and your ska band out kid hey I
played trumpet like a boss in Azkaban
don't you judge me
Miska moon the thus communist manifested
and thus Communist Manifesto had a
chance back in the day a look off into
the distance and reminiscence about that
rad horn section yeah my horn section
hey it's Emma P hey it's Emma P no dad
that's mr I didn't meet Emma P until I
was hunting in high school honey I
promise you wholeheartedly that I will
never stop mixing those two up dad Emma
R has been my best friend since I was
seven give it like a little bit of
effort all right Emma P was the one who
Oh
fired a flame that pooped her pants she
fired a flaming tennis ball at a police
station oh what a bad lighter fluid
tennis ball tennis racket right dad that
was you oh what a badass I am hell yeah
all right I was a wild child I was six
when you did it okay Amanda I wasn't
aiming for the police station but it
just happened that there
a police station in the vicinity of
where I wanted to hit a flaming tennis
ball yeah I remember you explaining that
to the police they didn't believe me
either anyway I got to show this to Emma
or later she'll get a kick out of the
first photograph oh the first
photography award he ever won yeah and
it got us a $20 gift card to make
Fridays and then you got food poisoning
from the cheesy tostada blasts I think
he meant food poisoning you know with
the Z still can't drive past make fried
A's without gagging still proud of you
though Amanda reaches deep down into the
box and pulls out one last photo
neither of us say a word we stare at the
frame neither of us say a word we stare
at the photo for a long moment I finally
decide to break the silence this is a
day we adopted you oh it's kind of funny
story the day we brought you home we got
into a car accident what's not anything
big just like a fender bender in a
parking lot but of course I was freaking
out and the little old lady who crashed
into us from freaking out and they
didn't want what to do your father oh
man
he olds my hand and looks me directly in
the eyes the calmest I've ever seen him
he says it's okay it's all gonna be okay
he was right you know I stared the
picture for longer maybe too long I miss
him I can't even imagine what it must be
like for Amanda she Pat's me on the back
come on pops we got to finish packing
the moving van won't wait forever you're
right Oh Amanda not pile into the car
and take one last look at the old house
so many memories here hard to believe
your father and I brought this place
bought this place almost 20 years ago
hey remember when I shattered the front
window playing catch you always had very
strong arms
dad arms if you ask me hey remember when
I shattered the other front window
pretending to be a robot who breaks
windows you are a very imaginative child
hey remember what I broke the back
window we get it Amanda you break stuff
and there'll be plenty more stuff to
break in the new place
memories de makin stuff to break you
ready we sit in silence for a moment I
watched my daughter grow up in
house will forever hold the place in my
heart but it stings a little bit to
leave it behind
I'm ready the moving van begins to pull
away and I get the car into position to
follow it I wash our house our old house
disappear in the rearview mirror so so
what so sell me on our cool new pad
clear my throat and do my best cheesy
announcer voice oh this is what I was
born for nestled in beautiful scenic
downtown Maple Bay our new house
features multiple places to sleep not
only are their bedrooms for your
sleeping pleasure but couches in floor
space where you can yes catch a wink
what a deal I mean if sleep weren't for
the weak you sleep more than anyone I
know I admit my faults pops I keep it
real
anyway it's also smaller than our last
house cozier one might argue good spin I
think it's great
what would be closer to a lot of cool
stuff that we can walk to so I don't
have to waste gas and I mean try to park
downtown is you know Amanda you know
you're gonna have to learn to parallel
park at some point right not gonna
happen pops I think someone needs to do
a three-point turn on their attitude I
don't know how to do that either
have you met the neighbors yet not yet
but the neighborhood seems pretty quiet
so you won't have to chase any rowdy
teams off your lawn you're the very teen
you mock when you say that honey I'm in
my last year of high school
I'm practically dust yeah you're a real
boy don't you dare
senior dad I know where this is going so
what's item number one on the new house
agenda well first we'll need to forage
paths through the solid wallet boxes is
blocking the living room I still have to
install the washer and dryer we need to
go grocery shopping Bob's cool your jets
you have to promise me that we're gonna
take a break and explore the
neighborhood okay okay you're right
we'll get some work done and then check
the area we pull up to the new house and
step outside lawn is freshly mown in the
for sale sign is still in the yard yeah
oh boy
and with a swift kick from Amanda the
for sale sign is no more nice for
sweetpea I got a problem with authority
and speaking I'm so proud man all that
karate chopping tuckered me out I could
really go for a sandwich an ice cream
sandwich
sweetie it's 10:00 a.m. let's see see
did you even seal the dogs in the park
nearby oh you know it thanks for moving
us to an area where the dog two-person
ratio is very high my favorite ratio I
only want what's best for you
I hope you're prepared for the frequency
at which I interrupt conversations to
yell dog to rock it way up I mean you do
that a lot always hey it's a dog wait
false alarm it was this a funny-shaped
Rock if you want to see real dogs so bad
let's go to that park around the corner
oh yeah oh yes I do always try to make
others around you happy Oh Amanda I
begin to stroll through the neighborhood
I can't believe how beautiful it is
outside kids are playing in the street
the flowers are in bloom and the faint
smell of a nearby barbeque drifts
through the air this place is nice too
nice I don't trust it good eye honey you
can never be too careful see that baby
in the stroller over there government
operative we're on to you baby we walk
for a while and eventually end up in a
small Park toddlers chase each other
through the playground and dogs of all
shapes and sizes romp through the grass
it's pretty crowded but Amanda spots a
nice empty bench we start to make our
way over it when heads up Oh a frisbee
suddenly hits me in the face oh the
Corgi with the neat plaid handkerchief
tied around its neck bounds up to me
wagging its tail oh my head
did you do this doggy bark he runs
around in a circle and nudges my leg
with his nose Oh God this is the cutest
dog Oh in part upon your wisdom tiny dog
woof woof oh what's that I'm already too
late my fate was predetermined for me
long ago I have no real agency in this
cruel timeline
ruff-ruff right I am the master of my
domain for fate is unknowable Thank You
wise dog arf you definitely could have
caught that a guy in a Hawaiian shirt
jogs over to us and takes the frisbee
from me you know frisbees are
traditionally caught with your hands not
with your face let's see I'll catch it
with my teeth next time oh yeah well you
caught me off guard this round not again
not ever again I'm just messing with you
I'm Brian by the way I'm mark and this
is my daughter Amanda look over at
Amanda only to find her sitting on the
ground rubbing the Doug's tummy hey your
dog's cool Oh
Maxwell sure loves the attention it's
great to see another father and daughter
out on a sunny day where's yours
Brian Jasper's over to the grassy knoll
where a young girl sits on a checkered
blanket she's reading a book bigger than
her head she puts it down and heads over
to us this is Daisy she's reading the
brother Karamazov kurama's off her
teacher tells me that she is reading the
cambrian her teacher tells me that she
has the reading comprehension skills
I can't even sentence how old is she
Dan she's a precocious little youngster
what my natural dad instinct it's in I
must drag Oh my natural dagon NSYNC it's
kicked my natural dad instinct kicks in
I must brag about my child's
accomplishments oh no it's happening but
what the [ __ ] go on Daisy tell them
about yourself
I that's my girl Amanda get in there I
love it marks HP 80 Brian's HP 80 Oh
oh my god oh my oh my god okay all right
brag I'm gonna brag Amanda here just
recently won a local photography award
Wow congratulations Brian listen Stacey
actually just won a statewide poetry
contest
you lose 1500 God all right daughter go
for it can't switch daughters all right
do I have items all right great cards
band-aids spelling bee photo child art
off spelling bee photo got a bless that
out fumbling through your phone's
browser you man to pull off a photo of a
man to winning your 10th grade spelling
bee Wow congratulations Amanda Danny
Daisy is getting prepped for annual
spelling bee right now hopefully this
will be your third win in a row
yikes you lose 5 HP Daisy just started
weekly chess club at her elementary
school computer lab she's the president
too of course dang my high school
doesn't have a chess club or a computer
no I can't lose
oh great card uh art no band-aid I don't
know that that's for me probably child
art you unfurl your wallet to reveal a
tiny copy of a drawing of a cornucopia
Amanda did in the first grade cute it
isn't very impressive but a man that
genuinely appreciates you holding on to
Ryan loses 10 HP you regain 20 hell yeah
it's 8 some of me
Oh Daisy sold enough candy bars this
year to get a top prize a canoe we're
taking it out next weekend how's that
even possible a man who could barely get
one of those sticky hand things is extra
powerful you lose 20 HP no I'm gonna
beat you what if I got great card go you
pull a wrinkled copy of Amanda's last
great card out of your back pocket dad
awesome grades
Brian loses 25 HP you really carry that
around everywhere
ouch maybe it is did I mention Daisy
said her first word at 10 months daddy
Amanda's was potty still cute but maybe
this isn't the time to bring it up you
lose 10 Oh God Oh its neck and neck I
don't have any items left I got a
band-aid I'm gonna use that with a
flourish you produce a band-aid from
your pocket take a knee and start to
apply to Amanda's arm Amanda what are
you doing dad
being a protective parent anyone would
agree it was an unusual chest Daisy here
is all of her adult teeth never out of
cavity either Amanda self-consciously
pushes her lips together to hide the
teeth it's extra powerful you lose 20 oh
no right no huh bragging last week
unprompted a man too helped an old woman
with her grocery bags it's extra
powerful lose 20 ha words aren't all
Daisy's good at by the way her math is
amazing one time I actually called her
to double check my numbers before I made
a cut for the support beam you did that
more than once dad doesn't that say
about him more about him than it does
about Daisy still you lose 10 dang he's
really got us beat boy it's been such a
treat getting to meet you too did he
have to add insult energy injury by
being such a gracious winner pokeymon
was never my strong suit
who did flop at the bandmate would have
been so weird so I take it you guys are
new to the neighborhood we just moved in
do you live around here
yeah we live in that cul de sac down
next to the coffee shop what a
coincidence that's where we live - small
world
yeah Daisy and I are in that little
ranch-style house on the corner I know
that house it's just like ours but
slightly bigger and better landscape
does this guy have to outdo me at
everything
damn what a lovely place well I don't
want to take up any more of your time
really nice meeting you guys you'll have
to stop by at some point yeah definitely
bye Brian and Daisy walk further into
the park with max well happily try
living along in tow do you get the
feeling that he was trying to one-up us
trying and succeeding I can't believe
that kids only 10 what was I even doing
at her age I believe you had a bit of a
thing for horses
shame that didn't pan out could have
majored in comparative horse studies
it's not too late to minor in horse
creative writing too close to the truth
dad let us never again speak of the
fantastic adventures of sir horsing
tyndall brave and heppa concession parts
by Amanda
laughs off the horse epic and walk
around the park a bit more enjoying the
day Oh Oh let's go to the coffee shop
let's go I got to get my hands on a nice
hot cup of the old bean juice don't call
it the old bean juice ever again or I'm
gonna be useless all day I think we
passed the coffee shop on the way here
maybe we could check that out let's do
it have you ever read oh no we walk down
the street to the coffee spoon a little
cute little place on the corner man this
is such a convenient walking distance
from our place I mean I guess what's
wrong why would I go somewhere else and
drink coffee on a couch when I could
just drink the better coffee at home on
my own couch and not have to make
awkward eye contact with other people at
least one AM home some random guy isn't
gonna come up and sit on the recliner
next to me and I won't feel like a
little weird about it because
technically he's not sitting in my table
but he is very much within my personal
zone dad what's the etiquette when you
have a dirty mug is there a bin do you
go set it on the counter because you
don't know where to put it where do you
leave it there and feel your face flush
hot with shame as you considered the
possibility of if there is in fact a bin
somewhere just have a second you and now
you're that jerk who left their mark dad
are you just afraid to meet new people
yes Amanda always in forever we walk
inside oh hey are you doing the inside
of the coffee shop is incredibly warm
and inviting vinyl records line the
walls and patrons lounge around the
well-worn in couches some cool tunes
spin on a record player next to a little
stage welcome to the coffee spoon guys
how's it going
what's with the name oh it's uh it's got
um it's mentioned in this poem I like it
I thought it was a good idea at the time
and I suppose now it's still a good idea
because like the business is still
running right the people ask me that
question all the time and I give them
the same answer every time and now I'm
standing and rambling and I'm sure we're
all getting more and more uncomfortable
the more I keep talking but man we're in
it now and I can't stop it's just like
me
so what'll it be
I scan the chalkboard menu and I'm
immediately overwhelmed I'll have a god
speed you black coffee iced Tegan and
Sara chai Antwoord I just I just I like
plain black coffee that's all I want
a classic Oh iced other's hearts not
quite the eggplants but hearts are good
too the classic I don't get it oh it's a
pun
Godspeed you black Emperor is a really
amazing an influential progressive rock
band known for their sweeping sounds
Gibson hey I'm doing coming right up for
you I have a macchiato DiMarco please
coming right up do you want that in
small/medium or biggie smalls um medium
weight is biggie smalls bigger smalls I
should change this [ __ ] Matt sets out to
meet her make our drinks and Amanda and
I take a seat in one of the couches
what's his deal but the man make puns
they're cool the bands and you listen to
anyway hey ed sheeran is a goddamn Saint
he's not really a band but yeah whatever
hey Scott was cool ones this couch is
actually pretty comfy maybe not come for
your than our couch but it's alright
good lumbar support you sink right into
it good lumbar okay it's comfier than
our couch Amanda no jeez man this place
is right next to our house and that guy
seems not only cool but also just as
uncomfortable talking to other people as
you are hey you should totally become
friends with him I don't know come on
what'd we say about meeting new people I
can't meet new people if I always stay
inside and also don't go outside and
also don't talk to people see we're
making progress Matt sets our drinks
down at our table and I mean we burn the
roof of my mouth good one hi we're new
in the neighborhood
I'm Amanda and this is my dad mark all
right I'm pleased to meet you both you
ought to come by when my daughter's
hanging around the shop you two might
get along yeah I'm sure we'll maybe come
in from time to time
man it kicks my leg from under the table
I'm sure we'll be in here a lot you know
what let me get you guys opinion on
something Matt goes into the back and
comes out with a fresh blade off
something that smells amazing I'm
working on a new banana bread recipe and
I need help coming up with a name for it
well I think we're gonna have to taste
tested first so we can get the full
flavor profile of
you know and really appreciate the
flavor sensation of Amanda nods
vigorously she knows this game yeah we
need to give that Nana bread a taste if
you want us to do a free creative labor
I think that would be kamesha it - I've
taught her well we've trained for this
day I was just gonna give you guys free
banana bread anyway right yes that's
okay
Matt serves us each a piece man and I
happily chow down this is amazing
thanks the secret ingredient is bananas
so many ideas I'm stumped well I think I
might only be able to give you dad
banned puns but I'll give it a shot ooh
banana bread Kennedy's grateful banana
bread right said banana bread whoo I
don't know I don't understand that last
one grateful banana bread it would be
better if he was just grateful bread I'm
gonna go with grateful banana bread like
the gym oh no no I take it back
that actually has a nice ring to it
really yeah grateful banana bread strong
decisions
that's art baby well you seem to like it
but the black clouds seem to be the
negative response I wanted to say baby
because I thought it would sound cool
but once I said it I realized that it
doesn't just sound good coming out of my
mouth
maybe I should just leave saying baby do
the professionals you got that baby
enjoy your coffee thanks baby see it
sounds good when you say across the way
a man catches my eye he sits by himself
brooding over a cup of coffee our eyes
meet just for a moment hastily look away
hoping you didn't catch me staring who's
that man we finished up our drinks and
head out thanks for stopping in take
care okay now that we're full of
caffeine we're - oh I should get back to
unpacking we've got a lot on my plate
right now did you know that moving is
one of the biggest sources of stress for
adults is it right behind the constant
fear that you smell bad and everyone's
too polite to tell you probably do I
smell bad Manny gives me a whiff you're
fine pops let's go home see ya I don't
even remember if I got your name I get
to work on packing in various boxes
around the living room a couple hours
pass and I get some good work done the
washer/dryer unit is both washing and
drying and we get
to walk through the living room without
tripping over boxes first visitor
already I'll walk over to the door and
opening hello Oh
a handsome clean-cut man stands up my
door brandishing a plate of cookies
Beauty pie is that you Joseph oh where
are my manners my name is Joseph I'm
your next-door neighbor oh yes hi I'm
mark that's what my name is I saw the
moving van and thought I'd bring over
some cookies
my daughter Christy wanted me to let you
know she baked them herself Joseph wings
and whispers between you and me she's a
sprinkled in some chocolate chips we
both share laughs kids right Wow cookies
uh nice to meet you Joseph hands her a
plate of cookies with a smile well
thanks for the cookies Amanda disappears
with the cookies Amanda come and she's
gone that's my daughter her name is
Amanda she's a jerk daughters are tough
sons are also tough children in general
just tough I hear that I mean it'd have
to be something wrong with you to try to
raise more than two I have four kids
Oh amen don't worry you didn't mean to
be rude no no this is the first neighbor
I've met in my social life is already in
a tailspin I wonder if it's too late to
move again yeah okay it's the missus
around mister actually and no not
anymore
he died oh I'm sorry for your loss no no
it's all right
Wow this is uncomfortable we stand there
quietly for a moment acutely aware of
how awkward we both made things I'm
sorry can you close the door real quick
I look at Joseph quizzically but comply
after a second I hear a knock on the
door i opening see Joseph standing there
with a huge smile hey I'm your new
neighbor Joseph I promise to not talk
about your dead spout this time I'm
throwing a barbecue for the cul-de-sac
and I'd love for you to come by and meet
the rest of the neighbors in our
community what do you say pal oh I love
reintroductions oh you're so charming
I'm so handsome that sounds great my
daughter Amanda and I would love to stop
by also for kids is a perfectly normal
amount of children to have we should
seal the deal well neighbors see at 3:00
p.m. sharp on Saturday sure thing
neighbor Oh justice starts walking away
but stops to think for a second turns
around
hey in all seriousness raisin get on
your own can't be easy you ever need to
talk about stuff I'm the youth minister
of Church down the street oh I don't
know I wouldn't really consider myself a
youth you look pretty young to me
yourself with that Joseph's gone he
seemed nice manna walks back my living
room crumbs on her face and cookie in
hand it was a smoothest recovery I've
ever seen I should be taking notes see
you're already fitting in great cookies
they're gone I'm sorry that makes you
feel any better they weren't very good
so we ate all of them anyway I guess
that makes a break time any ideas
Joseph probably wants his plate back oh
man okay I'm getting too caught up into
this because I've been playing this for
like 30 minutes and and I'm like super
super super into it this is this is so
charming so funny I love it so I'm gonna
end this episode here I don't know if
I'm just about to be on the precipice of
something else cool but I'm gonna this
is a good introduction to this we got
into the neighborhood we met a few of
the neighbors we saw one of the dark and
brooding ones but we've got more to meet
so thank you everybody so much for
watching I am so eager to play this game
it is so it's so charming it's so good
to see something like this come out of
this like oh man so if you want to play
this game for yourself I'll put a link
to the description it's available on
Steam right now and buy it it supports
all the amazing developers who out of
hand in making this game and let me know
what you think down the comments below
thank you again everybody for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]